what is my blood type who's asking
mr. Kolbert we must ask you some
questions okay
how many foreign friends do you have how
many foreign friends do I have the
Canadians count are they foreign tons I
have tons of foreign friends one two
three four
I'm in show business it's just a
passport orgy I'll be good
passport orgy would be great everybody
throws the passport into a ball and you
pick up which country having sex with
tonight fun is that something you would
do I'm obviously the right way what is
your favorite film by Roman Polanski my
favorite Roman Polanski film I don't
know if I've seen a Roman Polanski film
not sure if I can at this point
Oh Film Festival Roman Polanski and Bill
Cosby
what is the make of your car I Drive a
Tesla the name of my car is
Venga lot Venga lot is the ship of a
arendelle the mariner who tarried in a
vernian who built a ship of timber
felled and nim brothel to sailor in he
is the father of Elrond from the Lord of
the Rings and he sails over to Valar
from middle-earth to get the Valar to
help fight in the war of the summer ills
against Morgoth and they finally do but
he lives undying doom by flying across
the sky forever in his ship bingo lot
with a silmaril tied to his brow for he
is the Herald of the morn who gives hope
to men that day will come again so
that's my car
what's your car what shoe size do I wear
ten and a half D what glove size do I
wear who knows their glove size
what am i a Vallot really there's a
glove large is the fur lined glove are
we talking isotoners like throttling
gloves like murder you but these aren't
the right size murdering gloves Amit
what is my blood type should I know that
should I know the I should what's your
blood type
Oh Oh positive what do you you an EMT
what's their story
this is what worries me enough they
later go where there is any sign that he
was not right it was well he knew a lot
about blood not just this is pointless
he said since he was a kid he collected
blood time just uncertainty question I
don't know my blood type delicious is my
blood type just a little over the top
sprinkle a little or just an interesting
finishing round the edge of a plate you
know a little drizzle on the edge of the
plate and go like a dip your food in it
or not we are done here that's all what
we have everything we need